[Musik]
ein Schweizer Staatsbürger sitzt in
Thailand im Gefängnis er wurde zu
dreieinhalb Jahren Haft verurteilt weil
er versucht hat seine ehemaligen
Arbeitgeber zu erpressen die in den
größten Finanzskandal unserer Zeit
verwickelt sind durch seine Beschwerden
hat Xavier der Welt den sensationellen
Diebstahl von mehreren Milliarden
Franken offenbart es ist die
unglaubliche Geschichte die zum
unheimlichen Ende der Bank der
italienischen Schweiz führt doch Xavier
ist der einzige der dafür bezahlen muss
[Musik]
malaysische Schatten von Philipp blau
und altes Sophia
[Musik]
24 mai 2016 der Fall explodiert die BSI
hat die gesetzlichen Bestimmungen zur
Geldwäsche schwer verletzt mit diesem
harten Urteil kündigt die Schweizer
Aufsichtsbehörde Finma eine noch nie da
gewesene Maßnahme an die BSI muss
verschwinden ein Erdbeben auf dem
Tessiner Finanzplatz doch der große
Skandal erstreckt sich über vier
Kontinente insgesamt sind drei bis vier
Milliarden Franken verschwunden
buchstäblich gestohlen sagen Ermittler
in verschiedenen Ländern Geldwäsche
Korruption und ein riesiges schwarzes
Loch das die älteste Bank des Kantons
Tessin verschlingen wird
[Musik]
als ich Thailand verließ war das Essen
im Gefängnis knapp es gab trotz der
schrecklichen Hitze keine Ventilatoren
sogar das Wasser war begrenzt Zeitungen
waren verboten und es gab keine
Möglichkeit mit der Außenwelt zu
kommunizieren
in ihrem Haus in Genf ist Laura seit
Monaten in einen schwierigen und nicht
ungefährlichen Kampf verwickelt um die
Freilassung ihres Mannes zu erreichen
recherchiert sie sammelt Beweise und
meldet den Fall den Schweizer Behörden
Laura kämpft gegen die fragwürdige
Justiz eines fernen Landes aber vor
allem gegen mächtige Leute die daran
interessiert sind Xavier hinter Gittern
zu lassen
[Musik]
wenn man all das Geld sieht das
gestohlen wurde und all die Millionen
die sie haben dann versteht man auch die
Entschlossenheit mit der sie versuchen
ihre Taten zu verbergen und daraus zu
kommen sind sie bereit alles zu tun
und Laura sind nur ein Teil der
Geschichte die immer wieder die BSI
streift aber wie sind Sie in diese
Geschichte hineingeraten es ist
unvermeidlich mit ihm anzufangen mit
einer je brasag dem autoritären
Premierminister von Malaysia im Jahr
2009 richtete er den ersten development
burhat Fonds kurz one MdB Fonds mit
mehreren Milliarden Dollar ein um die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung des Landes
zu fördern er betraut joolo den
gewieften Spross einer wohlhabenden
malaysischen Familie und Freund des
stiefsohns des Premierministers mit der
Leitung des Unternehmens das ist da jo
low der Regisseur des großen Betrugs der
beginnt in Genf an den Ufern des Genfer
Sees arbeitet ein weiterer Protagonist
der Geschichte Tarik oberait ein
Schweizer Herkunft der sich mit dem
Inhaber einer finanzberatungsfirma
anfreundet Xavier husto
mein Mann stand Tarek damals sehr nah er
hatte eine besondere Zuneigung zu ihm
als ich meinen Mann kennenlernte hatte
Tarik kein Geld es war wie der ihm halt
er bot ihm an sich in seiner Firma
Fingern vor einzurichten so konnte Tarek
ober-id ein Büro haben und es gab ihm
auch eine gewisse Glaubwürdigkeit für
die Firma die er gerade gegründet hatte
in Genf die Pedro Saudi eine kleine
Ölgesellschaft große Ambitionen leere
Kassen später ein Büro in London in der
Zwischenzeit haben Laura Xavier einen
Traum sie wollen sich in Thailand ein
neues Leben aufbauen sie brechen 2008
auf es ist eine sehr glückliche Zeit
Heirat Geburt eines Kindes ein
touristisches Vorhaben doch da erwacht
ihr Freund Tarek wieder zum Leben
meinen Mann mehrmals an und zuerst sagt
er er wolle nicht sein Angestellter
werden aber sein Jobangebot und das
meines Mannes war sehr verlockend sogar
unglaublich in Bezug auf Gehalt und Boni
und auch für das Niveau des neuen
Geschäfts tarekte mehrere Wochen lang
darauf bis Xavier mich fragte was hältst
Du davon ich sagte ihm nach Thailand
können wir immer noch warum gehen wir
also nicht nach London und probieren es
dort wir können jederzeit nach Thailand
zurückkehren warum also nicht diese
Chance
nutzenbritannia birkeniter
[Musik]
london ist eine weitere obligatorische
Station auf unserer Suche wir kommen an
einem Tag dort an indem die britische
Presse immer noch über den one MdB
Skandal spricht in der britischen
Hauptstadt treffen wir auf eine weitere
Schlüsselfigur unserer Geschichte sie
lebt unter Polizeischutz mehrmals haben
Hacker Ihren Computer gehackt und
Malaysia hat sie offiziell als
Staatsfeind bezeichnet
Brown wurde in Malaysia geboren seit
Jahren prangert sie die Korruption in
dem asiatischen Land an in dem der
Durchschnittslohn nur 300 Dollar pro
Monat beträgt clair gründete den sarawag
Report dessen Inhalt uns dabei leiten
wird den Betrug und die Verwicklung der
BSI darin genau zu verstehen
politischen Lebens hat Premierminister
Jeep ein paar Dinge verstanden
er hat verstanden dass alles einen Preis
hat man muss eine riesige Menge Geld
anhäufen damit man Malaysia
kontrollieren kann man kann alles kaufen
was man will Propaganda ein gutes Image
von sich selbst wirklich alles er hat
viel in persönliche Beziehungen
investiert das Geld von One MdB wurde
dafür verwendet er hat riesige Beträge
aus den öffentlichen Fonds auf seine
Privatkunden überwiesen
eines entscheidenden Tages september
2009 eine Gruppe von Freunden mit dem
malaysischen Premierminister Jeep auf
einer Yacht an der Côte nicht wirklich
war bei der Party dabei eigentlich hatte
er alles arrangiert hier ist Tarik obaid
euer Mann aus Genf und von Pedro Saudi
das sind die Tochter und der Sohn von
brosmer und Magie es ist ein sehr
kleiner Kreis aber alle Akteure sind da
alle
ein entscheidendes Spiel wird hier
gespielt das Treffen wurde organisiert
um ein Joint Venture zwischen one MdB
und Pietro Saudi zu unterzeichnen in ein
paar Stunden ist das Geschäft unter Dach
und Fach sie haben es alle eilig aus dem
malaysischen vorsohlen so schnell wie
möglich mehr als eine Milliarde Dollar
an Pedro Saudi überwiesen werden dass
sich von einer leeren Kiste in einen
Safe voller Geld verwandelt mit an Bord
ist auch der junge Prinz Turki sechster
Sohn des Königs von Saudi-Arabien ein
neuer Teilhaber von Pedro Saudi er
bringt seinen Prestige trächtigen
Familiennamen mit an Bord und zusammen
mit seinen Komplizen wird der
millionenschwere Provisionen kassieren
diese junge Männer wollen den
Premierminister weiß machen das ist ein
großes Unternehmen gibt und dass man
investieren kann von einer Milliarde
kassieren sie 300 Millionen aber niemand
sollte wissen was mit den anderen 700
Millionen oder so passiert und das war
der Deal
ungefähr 700 Millionen werden auf das
persönliche Konto des malaysischen
Premierministers gehen noch vor der
Küste von Monte Carlo nimmt Joe low
Kontakt mit der BSI in Genf auf wie aus
der von Claire gefundenen E-Mail
hervorgeht
würden Sie mir bitte dringend die
bsi-daten schicken der Kunde muss die
Überweisung der Gelder veranlassen und
so planen Sie bereits am Abend des 28
September die Überweisung der Mittel an
die BSI
aber der Weg nach Genf ist versperrt
verifica Operation die bsi-tochter will
die Risiken der Operation überprüfen er
hält aber nicht alle erforderlichen
Unterlagen einer ihrer leitenden
Angestellten der anonym bleiben möchte
erzählt uns wie es zu der Entscheidung
kam Jolo abzulehnen
wie kommt es dass ihr Leute von der BSI
Genf eine so gewaltige Transaktion über
eine Milliarde Dollar ablehnt
es war eine Entscheidung die in unserem
Team gereift war und unter diesen
Umständen waren wir nicht gezwungen die
Zentrale in Lugano zu informieren
letztendlich waren es nicht klar woher
die Summe kam und wofür sie bestimmt war
so allen hier war das der einzige Grund
nun es gab noch mehr sie erzählten uns
zum Beispiel dass sie in Zentralasien
ein großes Stück Land gekauft hätten das
reich an Öl sei sie haben uns sogar
eingeladen es zu besichtigen ich ging
mit einigen Kollegen dorthin ich stand
vor einem Feld auf dem es nur Schafe gab
aber ich versichere Ihnen dass es nicht
einmal eine Spur von Öl dort gab ich
meine das war überhaupt nicht
überzeugend wir haben gehört dass sie
auch Xavier husto ihren Mandanten der
Petro Saudi gut kannte um Rat gefragt
haben und auch er hat ihnen geratenes
sein zu lassen schauen Sie ich will
Ihnen nur sagen dass in Genf nicht nur
eine Führungskraft die Entscheidung traf
diese wichtige Einlage abzulehnen das
gesamte Management-Team war beteiligt
und stimmte dagegen
aber wir erklären sie sich dass die
Milliarden Einlage die sie abgelehnt
hatten später über die Niederlassungen
Singapur wieder bei der BSI Lugano
auftaucht
ich weiß es nicht jedenfalls entsprachen
die Modalitäten der BSI in Singapur
nicht unserer Philosophie unser Ansatz
war entschieden vorsichtiger ich würde
fast sagen konservativ in Asien ist das
anders man riskiert mehr und erwartet
eine höhere Rentabilität
nehmen wir das bonusbeispiel für
mittlere führungskräfte werden in der
Schweiz etwa zwei zusätzliche Gehälter
pro Jahr gezahlt in Singapur können es
zehnmal so viele sein verstehen sie ich
glaube
queen.de also streckt an die
Vorschriften zur Bekämpfung von
Geldwäsche aber Joe low gibt nicht auf
er muss eine Lösung finden er wendet
sich an die kurzbank in Zürich wo er
einen hochrangigen Manager kennt
Hans-peter Brunner Schweizer Topmanager
der als der beste für die Suche nach
asiatischen Kunden gilt es ist die Zeit
in der die BSI beschließt sich auf Asien
zu konzentrieren um einem starken
Rückgang der Rentabilität
entgegenzuwirken
Singapore Singapur wird die operative
Basis sein von der aus der Neustart
erfolgen soll und in Lugano wurde
beschlossen Hans-peter Brunner für die
Leitung des Projekts zu gewinnen
und sind die etwa 100 Mitarbeiter von
kurz folgen ihm ein großer Transfer
ungewöhnlich in der Bankenwelt eine
Bestätigung für sein Charisma Brunner
verschwendet keine Zeit und öffnet die
Türen der BSI für die Gelder seines
Freunde
London seit dem Frühjahr 2010 arbeitet
Xavier bei Pedro Saudi er hatte nicht
sofort Zugang zu ALLEN Akten aber nach
und nach versteht er das große
Geldsummen durch Pedro Saudi geflossen
und verschwunden sind
je mehr er dort arbeitete je mehr
Dokumente er einsehen konnte desto mehr
wurde ihm das Ausmaß des Geschäfts und
der Geschehnisse klar wir reden hier
nicht über ein paar 10000 Franken
sondern über Millionen Milliarden ich
erinnere mich an den Tag an dem er zu
mir sagte ist dir klar wie viel sie
gestohlen haben
wir am meisten ärgert ist die Tatsache
dass Pedro Saudi die Abmachungen nicht
einhält er hält oft kein Gehalt keinen
Bonus er zahlt die 15000 Franken Miete
pro Monat die das Unternehmen zahlen
sollte aus eigener Tasche außerdem sagt
er Laura habe das Geld seinen ehemaligen
Freund Tarek stark verändert
uns zu einer Weinprobe ein die 10.000 €
pro Person kostete aber sie ging nur 5
Minuten Terre beschloss sofort zu gehen
weil er sich langweilte 40 bis 50 000 €
in ein paar Minuten auszugeben war kein
Problem
des Geldes ist Tarek zu einem Menschen
geworden der sich für den König der Welt
hält der glaubt er könne jeden wie einen
niemand behandeln
der König der Welt hat ein zunehmend
schwieriges Verhältnis zu Xavier er
kritisiert ihn in der Öffentlichkeit
spricht schlecht über seine Freunde
hasst seine Tattoos nennt ihn einen
Loser einen Verlierer 2013 verärgert
beschließen die Schweizer zurückzutreten
und da verlangt was ihm zusteht
Millionen an Rückständen
ich warte auf die heutige Bestätigung
über das Ende unserer Partnerschaft also
verlasse ich das Büro und warte darauf
dass du mir sagst wie du mit meiner
Abfindung Verfahren wirst herzlichst das
hat mein Mann an Tarek geschrieben der
darauf antwortet du Arschloch es ist
schön eine große Klappe zu haben aber
jetzt reicht's ein Wort von dir darüber
und es ist aus mit uns beiden
es ist aus im Sinne von es ist vorbei
das ist das Ende es ist nicht nur das
Ende ihrer Beziehung nein ich denke viel
mehr
zu diesem Zeitpunkt sieht Pedro Saudi
Xavi als Problem es kommt zur
Konfrontation und die Schweizer finden
er müsse sich schützen
um sich vor den Drohungen von Tarek zu
schützen bittet mein Mann um eine Kopie
des Servers von Pietro Saudi
[Musik]
stiehlt daraufhin tausende sensibler
Daten jetzt kennt er alle Geheimnisse
des Geschäfts mit one MdB er versucht
das zu bekommen was ihm zusteht zunächst
verspricht dem Pedro Saudi eine
Abfindung von 6 Millionen Dollar doch
daraus werden vier als der Vertrag
unterzeichnet ist Xavier gibt sich nicht
zufrieden er will die fehlenden 2
Millionen zusammen mit Laura beschließt
er nach Thailand zurückzukehren doch
eine Kopie der Daten von Pedro Saudi
bleibt in einem Bankschließfach der BSI
in Genf versteckt
ation
und natürlich fragte ich sie ob sie
irgendwelche Neuigkeiten über one MdB
hätten sie antworteten in der Tat ja
jemand versucht an einige Oppositionelle
heranzukommen und die hätten einige
interessante Daten sehen Sie wir haben
welche schauen Sie sie sich an ich hatte
mich eingehend mit dem Fall befasst und
konnte erkennen ob die Dokumente echt
waren und die die mir Vorlagen waren zu
genau um falsch zu sein die Malaysia
sagten zu mir er verlangt eine Menge
Geld
mein Mann hatte große Angst sie zu
treffen er kannte klären nicht der er
hätte sagen sollen sehen Sie das sind
sehr gefährliche Leute die viel Einfluss
und viel Geld haben und vor allem viele
gute Kontakt ist
personali
iOS
meinen Mann nach Thailand hat verfolgen
lassen hat von einer spionagefirma
telefonaufzeichnungen von Xavier
erhalten
seine telefonaufzeichnungen er wusste
alles wer ihn angerufen hat und wann
hast du bewegt sich sehr vorsichtig aber
jetzt hat er beschlossen sein Herz
auszuschütten über einen Mittelsmann
gelingt es Claire den Schweizer zu
kontaktieren sie macht einen Termin aus
das erste Treffen findet in einem Hotel
in Bangkok Stadt
ziemlich nervös ich war den ganzen Weg
nach Bangkok geflogen eine einzelne Frau
die sich mit einem Fremden treffen
wollte jemand sagte mir sogar er könnte
mit der Mafia in Verbindung stehen
dieser große
muskulöse Kerl auf ich dachte der könnte
mich umbringen aber er war sofort sehr
höflich
er sagte ich will 2 Millionen Dollar
und ich sagte wissen Sie ich habe noch
nie in meinem Leben für eine Story
bezahlt ich bin nur eine Journalistin
und ich habe keine zwei Millionen also
muss ich sie davon überzeugen mir die
Infos zu geben er sagte mir auch etwas
was ich jetzt besser verstehe
nämlich dass er eine finanzielle
Absicherung brauche ich weiß noch wie er
zu mir sagte du hast es mit mächtigen
Leuten zu tun klar diese Leute leben in
einer anderen Welt sie können mit jedem
machen was sie wollen und sie kommen
damit durch
ich war wirklich entschlossen diese
Geschichte zu bekommen so etwas passiert
selten
jedenfalls zeigte er mir die Dokumente
tausende von Daten die Beweise für einen
riesigen betrug enthalten
über 250.000 E-Mails findet sich die
ganze Geschichte die Journalistin ist
auf der Suche nach jemandem der die
Nachfrage der Schweizer befriedigen kann
und sie findet ihn es ist tongoon ein
malaysischer Verlags Magnat der der
Opposition nahe steht januar 2015 in
Singapur findet das entscheidende
Treffen statt der Verleger beruhigt
Xavier er wird ihm die zwei Millionen
Dollar zahlen
sie sind ein Gentleman und ich habe die
Festplatten bei mir aber dann hat der
Verlag ihn nie bezahlt
ich glaube tom wollte ihn wirklich
bezahlen aber in Malaysia kann man heute
für Straftaten belangt werden die es
gestern noch gar nicht gab und der
Verleger könnte so plötzlich für alles
verantwortlich gemacht werden die Angst
davor hielt ihn davon ab selbst als er
die Angriffe sah den er nicht ausgesetzt
war
Frühling 2015 mit den ersten Artikeln
von Claire explodiert der Skandal ihre
Enthüllungen alarmieren Petrus Saudi die
am Ende 1,8 Milliarden von One MdB
erhalten zu haben scheint der Kronzeuge
Xavier muss zum Schweigen gebracht
werden
es war alles sehr hart ein Dutzend
Polizisten kam herein durchsuchte unser
Haus beschlagnahmte alle unsere Computer
alle unsere Tablets alle unsere Telefone
sie steckten ihn einen Tag lang in eine
Zelle und flogen sie ihn in die
Hauptstadt 24 Stunden später saß er in
einem Gefängnis in Bangkok
[Musik]
juni 2015 Xavier ist verhaftet worden
angezeigt wegen versuchter Erpressung
seine Haftbedingungen sind schlecht und
sein thailändischer Verteidiger ein
Dilettant danke
schlimmsten Verbrecher einem
gefährlichen kriminellen auszuliefern
sie haben es im thailändischen
malaysischen und singapurischen
Fernsehen gezeigt
wie kam die Presse mit ins Spiel konnten
sie so schnell von Malaysia nach
Thailand reisen hatten sie wirklich die
Zeit ein Flugzeug zu erwischen nein
alles war von Anfang an geplant
und der Beweis dafür ist dass sie
bereits dort waren als Xavier
festgenommen wurde
[Musik]
laura hat keine Zweifel daran dass die
Führer von Pedro Sau die bestochen
worden waren wer Bangkok hat muss Xavier
hinter sich lassen
nach der Verhaftung erhielt ich einen
Anruf von seinem Anwalt der Anwalt hielt
den Hörer in der Hand und ich konnte
meinen Mann aus der Zelle schreien hören
und er schrie ich bin verhaftet worden
aber keine Sorge ich habe einen Anwalt
und von diesem Moment an war es ein
Abstieg in die Hölle
es stellt sich heraus dass hinter dem
Betrug mehr steckt als nur Pedro Saudi
zwei weitere Operationen dieser Art sind
bereits in die Wege geleitet worden
Milliarden Ströme der malaysische
Premierminister narci wird zugeben dass
er fast 700 Millionen erhalten hat aber
er wird eine wenig glaubhafte Erklärung
dafür abgeben es handele sich um ein
Geschenk von Saudi-Arabien das teilweise
zurückgezahlt wurde
diese Artikel stammt noch aus der
Anfangszeit als ich die richtigen
Informationen bekam und der Fall der
Bank der italienischen Schweiz eröffnet
wurde ich habe diese ersten Dokumente
gefunden aus denen hervorging wie joolo
Geld von kurz in Zürich zur BSI in
Singapur überwiesen hatte das war eine
riesige Enthüllung sie sollte er das
erklären
sie die Transaktionen der folgenden
Monate sehen
[Musik]
diese Einzahlung ging von kurz in Zürich
zur BSI in Singapur mit sieben
aufeinanderfolgenden Transaktionen der
Junior Domina seit Juni 2011 hat er 528
Millionen Dollar der oft genannten 700
Millionen überwiesen das ist das
gestohlene Geld
[Musik]
kaum 30 Jahre alt genießt Joe low das
gute Leben in vollen Zügen von Amerika
bis Europa machte sich mit seinen
Parties seinen Namen der Niki beach in
San Tropez ist ein Club für
privilegierte die berühmte Erbin Paris
Hilton gehört zu den Stammgästen hier
fließt der teuerste Champagner 50.000 €
pro Flasche und auch der
freundschaftsrabatt ist exzessiv so
kosten die Getränke zusammen nur
107.000 Euro aber Jolo kümmert sich auch
um seine eigenen Angelegenheiten er
investiert viel Geld in den USA wie das
US-Justizministerium bestätigt etwa 300
Millionen in Immobilien beiden
Plattenfirmen Hotels Luxus Flugzeuge und
sogar diesen Monet der für 57,5
Millionen Dollar gekauft wurde alles so
die Ermittler mit dem Geld das aus dem
One MdB vorgestohlen wurde und oft wir
Überweisung von der BSI eine kolossale
geldwäscheoperation und dann wäre da
noch Hollywood
Stiefsohn des malaysischen
Premierministers erhält von joolo den
Auftrag zur Gründung einer
Filmproduktionsgesellschaft und
finanziert den Film the wolf of wall
Street mit Leonardo DiCaprio in der
Hauptrolle es ist eine Film Denunziation
über Drogen Sport und die unfassbare
Gier die in der Finanzwelt herrscht es
klingt wie ein Witz wenn man bedenkt was
Joe in der BSI macht
[Musik]
ich habe die Liste seiner Unternehmen
gesehen die er bei der BSI in Singapur
eröffnet hatte er hatte Dutzende von
ihnen
eröffnete sogar sechs auf einmal wenn
die BSI einen Kunden hätte der unendlich
viele Firmen eröffnet und in vielen von
ihnen gab es nichts nun sicherlich hatte
die Bank die Möglichkeiten diese
Auffälligkeiten zu erkennen und zu sehen
das Laufen Transaktionen über die BSI
abgewickelt werden ich meine die Bank
könnte sich zumindest fragen warum
was weiß man bei der obersten BSI Lugano
über Joe low der viele Briefkastenfirmen
eröffnet es dauert einige Zeit bis die
Aussagen einiger leitender Angestellter
von damals zusammengetragen waren keiner
war bereit sein Gesicht zu zeigen sie
behaupten dass auch die
Bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt und das
Bankgeheimnis eine Rolle spielt auf dem
Parkplatz eines europäischen Flughafens
erklärte sich jedoch einer der damaligen
leitenden Angestellten der Bank bereit
uns zu treffen
glauben Sie mir November 2014 wusste ich
nicht einmal genau wer dieser Jolo war
ich wusste nur dass es diesen einen
reichen Kunden gab der one MdB in die
Bank eingeführt hatte aber ich wusste
dass Hans-Peter Brunner ihn sehr gut
kannte eines Tages zeigte mir ein
Kollege eine Zeitung und sagte sie mal
das ist der malaysische Kunde der uns
wohnen iMDB gebracht hat es war ein Bild
von Jolo mit Paris Hilton
also warte ich im nächsten
Verwaltungsrat um einige Informationen
über Jolo Informationen
aber hatten Sie denn irgendwelche
Zweifel
war deine Kommission natürlich wussten
sie von den besonders hohen Provisionen
die dieser Betreiber in unsere Bank
zahlte ich musste zugeben dass ich
jemand gefragt hat warum die Provisionen
zu unserem Gunsten so hoch waren und ob
dahinter nicht Verdächtige wenn nicht
sogar illegale Dinge stecken aus
Singapur hier wenn wir jedoch eine
beruhigende Antwort Herr Joe Low ist ein
sehr reicher Kunde und er hat es sicher
nicht nötig derartige Transaktionen zu
tätigen
und sie waren damit einverstanden
nun sehen Sie ich sage ihnen dass wir
bereits einen externen Wirtschaftsprüfer
Ernst den Young kontaktiert hatten der
die Operation im allgemeinen analysiert
hatte aber er war nicht näher auf das
Berufliche Profil von Joe low
eingegangen kein Profil ist super viele
fundamental wie ein grundlegender Punkt
die BSI muss den malaysischen vor nicht
verwalten sie muss das Geld nicht zum
Laufen bringen sie ist nur eine
Depotbank aber nur für die Verwahrung
des Geldes erhält sie eine Provision von
2 %, was 40 mal mehr ist als das was
normalerweise verlangt wird der Gewinne
BSI ist abnormal warum ist so großzügig
will er weniger Kontrolle durch die BSI
Männer kontrolliert
so das außergewöhnliche in dem Fall ich
würde sagen das außergewöhnliche in
diesem Fall sind die Summen um die es
geht und die Tatsache dass alle Personen
seines Banken seines Einzelpersonen die
an dieser Geldwäsche beteiligt waren
astronomische Summe erhalten
Rechtsanwalt Emanuele Stauffer weiß
wovon er spricht er hat sich bereit
erklärt zum ersten Mal und öffentlich
über die Angelegenheit zu sprechen die
ihm vertraut ist im Februar 2016 wurde
Staufer von der BSI als Leiter der
Rechtsabteilung eingestellt doch einige
Monate zuvor hatte ihn die Bank in
Lugano mit einer externen und
unabhängigen Evaluation beauftragt Stau
verdrang in die Büros in Lugano und
Singapur ein hatte Zugang zu allen
Dokumenten und fügte die Einzelteile der
Geschichte zusammen sein Bericht der
auch auf dem Tisch der Aufsichtsbehörde
landete ist sehr ausführlich
aber wenn eine Person wie joolo 100
konnten eröffnen wird er nicht sofort
Alarm geschlagen
natürlich sollte man dann Alarm schlagen
aber viel eher sollte man das tun wenn
Mittel ein und ausgehen
wenn man die Anzahl der Kunden sieht die
Volumina die Art der Transaktionen sieht
sagt man Nein
nachdem es sieben konnten am Tag
durchlaufen hat und zwar nicht 100.000
sondern 20 Millionen und sie immer noch
versuchen dafür eine einfache Begründung
zu finden finde ich das wieder ein
Problem haben
die von der Bank erhaltene Vergütung war
im Vergleich zu dem was sie hätte sein
sollen offensichtlich überhöht
dies war wahrscheinlich der wichtigste
Weckruf der hätte ertönen müssen aber
vor allem hätte er irgendwie ein
schlechtes Gewissen bereiten müssen denn
die von der Bank gebrachte Leistung
wurde so hoch vergütet
Alto jemand sagte uns es ist ein freier
Markt
das könnte eine Antwort sein vielleicht
ist es nicht die richtige Antwort
wenn wir über Risikomanagement sprechen
geht es weniger um Unwissenheit sondern
vielmehr um mangelnde Sorgfalt und
Unterlassung aus eigenem Interesse
aus
Bequemlichkeit dass man nicht in die
Tiefe schaut dass man bestimmte
Situationen nicht eingehen und kritisch
überprüft
[Musik]
er musste sagen dass er es nur fürs Geld
getan hat er musste sagen dass er den
Inhalt der Festplatten überhaupt nicht
kannte und das klären nicht wirklich
glaubwürdig sein
und dass er einige Dokumente gefälscht
habe
und zwar um Petro Saudi in ein gutes
Licht zu rücken
im Gefängnis von Bangkok bricht Xavier
husto zusammen er ist im ständigen Druck
der Gesandten von Pedro Saudi ausgesetzt
die anscheinend jederzeit in seine Zelle
eindringen können er macht sich Sorgen
um seinen Sohn und seine bedrohte Frau
schließlich gibt danach und
unterschreibt ein falsches Geständnis im
Gegenzug verspricht man ihm eine
schnelle Freilassung aber auch Pedro
Saudi nimmt eine fragwürdige Rolle an
der sich bei mir meldete zuerst benutzte
er nicht einmal seinen richtigen Namen
anfangs nannte er sich Paul Brown dann
änderte er seinen Namen in Paul Scott er
rief mich an und teilte mir mit dass er
wisse dass mein Mann noch andere
Dokumente andere Kopien besitze und dass
er sie bei BSI in Genf versteckt habe er
forderte mich auf sie zurückzugeben
ich sagte ihm dass ich ihn nicht traue
und er fragte mich was ich wolle ich
antwortete ihm ich will meinen Mann
sprechen sonst rühre ich keinen Finger
so hatte ich ihn noch nie erlebt am
Telefon sagte er zu mir Laura bitte tu
alles was sie dir sagen du musst alles
tun was Paul sagt du musst alles tun was
er von dir verlangt ich flehe dich an
also meldete sich bei mir und sagte ich
werde in zwei oder drei Tagen in Genf
sein sie müssen mir alle Informationen
geben sonst wird ihr Mann hier für 9
Jahre ins Gefängnis gehen
[Musik]
ein paar Tage später betritt Laura die
bsi-filiale in Genf sie begibt sich in
den Bereich der Schließfächer sie lehrt
das jenige in dem ihr Mann andere Kopien
der Festplatten mit den Geheimnissen von
One MdB und Pedro Saudi versteckt hatte
und dass sie nun Paul Finningen
übergeben muss
so versichert laura ist in Wirklichkeit
ein ehemaliger britischer Polizist den
Pedro Saudi auf sie angesetzt hat der
ihr wie ein Schatten folgt und sie
ständig einschüchtert
sicherlich haben Sie Xavier gesagt dass
ihm das Schlimmste passieren würde wenn
er mich nicht überzeugen könnte und ich
die Papiere nicht aushändigen würde sie
drohten ihm und sie drohten mir indem
sie sagten dass mein Mann bestenfalls
nach Malaysia ausgeliefert werden würde
ich wiederhole bestenfalls sie drohten
mir dass sie versuchen würden ihn zu
vergiften ihn zu töten
die Wochen und Monate nach der
Verhaftung waren die Hölle die Hölle
der Manager von Pedro Saudi der am
eindringlichsten versucht Laura zur
Zusammenarbeit zu bewegen ist Patrick
mahony der Direktor des Unternehmens mit
Mitteln die über bloßen Druckaufbau
hinausgehen
alle Leute gekauft die er brauchte bis
hinauf zur Spitze und verhaften zu
lassen aber es war nicht nur Pedro Saudi
der hinter diesen außergewöhnlichen
Manövern steckte letztere arbeitete mit
dem malaysischen Regierungschef nach
Jeep und seinem Umfeld zusammen
Maroni gab dies in einem aufgezeichneten
Telefongespräch zu und sagte hinter ihm
stehe der große Mann wie er den
Premierminister des Landes nennt
es ist Patrick der mich anruft und über
den Premierminister spricht
Abend erzählt im Moment hat er
schreckliche Angst dass Xavier seine
Entscheidung rückgängig macht und alles
abstreitet und sagt dass einige
schmutzige Dinge getan worden sind
das ist seine Position und er hat immer
noch Angst davor der Mann macht weiter
Stress es ist seine politische Karriere
die auf dem Spiel steht das ist alles
woran er denkt nichts anderes vergessen
Sie nicht dass wir alle in der Scheiße
sitzen
im Knast du bist allein mit deinem Kind
ich habe dich neulich gesehen und gesagt
dass ich mir Sorgen um Dich mache
aber ich sitze auch in der Scheiße und
viele andere sitzen auch in der Scheiße
da ist der Premierminister eines Landes
der in der Scheiße steckt weil er die
Scheiße mit hineingezogen wurde vergiss
das nicht
ja aber nur gesagt wir ist im Gefängnis
ja er ist im Gefängnis aber er hätte das
nicht tun müssen ich will mich nicht
wieder darüber aufregen
[Musik]
in triermonella cita wir betreten die
Stadt in der alles begann Kuala Lumpur
die Hauptstadt von Malaysia ihre
Modernität symbolisiert durch die
Zwillingstürme konzentriert sich auf das
glitzernde Finanz- und Handelszentrum
ein Bild das nicht die Realität des
restlichen Landes widerspiegelt das um
seinen Aufschwung kämpft
[Musik]
wir haben einen Termin mit einem
ehemaligen Premierminister der als Vater
der teilweisen wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung des Landes gilt der Mann
mahatia Mohammad ist heute der wahre
Führer der Opposition er spielt eine
wichtige Rolle bei der Enthüllung von
One MdB
die riesige Villa in der seine Büros
untergebracht sind wird diskret von der
Polizei des Regimes überwacht
martia war einer der ersten der die
Verantwortung und die illegalen Gewinne
des derzeitigen Regierungschefs
anprangerte ursprünglich war mal Art
hier ein Verbündeter von Jeep heute hält
er ihn für einen Diktator der sich der
Korruption bedient
das Gesetz in Malaysia existiert heute
nicht das Gesetz kann sie nicht
funktionieren der Regierungschef hat die
totale Kontrolle über die Polizei und
den Generalstaatsanwalt Ermittlungen
werden blockiert oder wenn sie
durchgeführt werden werden die
Ergebnisse verheimlicht er kontrolliert
alles
der Premierminister versucht sich mit
den einflussreichsten Leuten an zu
Freunden indem er Geld einsetzt und er
denkt dass sie ihn schützen werden wenn
ihm etwas passiert
in dem Fall von Xavier husto der in
Thailand inhaftiert ist nach was sagen
sie glauben sie dass er Monate lang im
Gefängnis bleiben wird vielleicht sogar
bis zur nächsten Wahl
ich weiß nicht wie lange er im Gefängnis
bleiben wird aber ich denke die
Schweizer Regierung hat jedes Recht sich
zu beschweren warum ist er immer noch
ein Gefangener obwohl er im August
entlassen werden sollte er hat
offensichtlich eine Menge Informationen
und ich denke es ist die Pflicht der
Schweizer Regierung an diese
Informationen zu kommen
und glauben sie dass na die stark genug
ist Thailand und die Auslieferung von
Xavier Husten hier in Malaysia zu bitten
ich weiß es nicht aber er könnte es tun
operiert nicht mit der Schweizer
Bundesanwaltschaft sie verhindert jede
Art von interner Untersuchung und die
Presse wird mundtot gemacht das ist
Frankie gum ein Mann der premiera china
steht er ist Vorsitzender der mächtigen
Vereinigung der Malaysia chinesischer
Herkunft er kennt mehrere
Parlamentsabgeordnete die alle loyal zum
Premierminister stehen Herr game will
nichts von einem Skandal wissen es
Skandal ist das etwa kein Skandal
ich glaube nicht dass das ein Skandal
ist offen gesagt Premierminister einer
Jeep ist ein sehr guter Mann und er ist
auch ein sehr bescheidener Mann unsere
Regierungschef hat mit dieser one
mdb-geschichte nicht zu tun
manchmal kommt so etwas vor wie in so
vielen anderen Ländern auch und viel
Malaysia dass ein sehr freies Landes in
dem jeder alles sagen kann
wie die Oppositionspartei aber ist Ihnen
bekannt dass es auch eine offizielle
us-untersuchung gibt
in der ihr Premierminister praktisch
beschuldigt wird sich einen Teil des
malaysischen Fonds angeeignet zu haben
was halten Sie von dieser Anschuldigung
ich weiß nicht warum ich kann mir diesen
amerikanischen Bericht nicht erklären
aber unsere Untersuchung hat ergeben
dass nichts gefunden wurde was in
direktem Zusammenhang mit unserem
Premierminister steht
Ihnen der Name
Jolo ist
ein Junge
ja ich habe von ihm gehört
und was halten Sie von ihm ehrlich
sagend ich weiß dass er dem
Premierminister nahe stehen soll aber
das glaube ich nicht sehen sie jeder
kann zu ihm gehen und sagen hallo Herr
Premierminister kann ich ein Foto mit
ihnen machen das ist kein Problem dann
können Sie sich vielleicht etwas mit dem
Foto einfallen lassen
ich würde sagen es ist jetzt an der Zeit
mit dieser one mdb-sache aufzuhören ich
will darüber nicht weiter sprechen
wir befinden uns vor einer Baustelle des
One MdB ein Bauprojekt zur Richtung
eines Finanzcenter
Lumpur führt uns ein Ort ansässiger
Kollege an einen Platz der als Symbol
für den Skandal steht auf diesem Gelände
sollte one MdB ein neues Finanzzentrum
bauen aber alles steht seit Jahren still
auch weil one MBB durch große
Raubüberfälle und fehl Investitionen
Schulden in Höhe von 11 Milliarden
Dollar angehäuft hat entgegen der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung stattdessen
ist der Staat gezwungen erhebliche
Kürzungen bei den Sozialleistungen
vorzunehmen und das Gelände wurde an die
Chinesen verkauft
die Schweizer Banken sollten eine
Mitverantwortung tragen denn die Banken
müssen herausfinden woher das Geld kommt
sie alle kennen das Problem der
Geldwäsche sie sollten vorsichtig sein
aber anscheinend haben sie nicht mit der
Sorgfalt gehandelt die von einer Bank
erwartet wird
der Premierminister hat das Geld
gestohlen wenn es sich um gestohlenes
Geld handelt und wir wissen wem es
gestohlen wurde sollte es meiner Meinung
nach an die Menschen die ursprünglichen
Eigentümer zurückgegeben werden ich
denke nicht dass es an den
Premierminister oder die derzeitige
Regierung zurückgegeben werden sollte
denn sie sind an der Sache Beteiligte
kriminelle Grünwald
[Musik]
sie verlassen Malaysia mit einem Gefühl
der Erleichterung das Land steht auf dem
letzten Platz was Menschen Rechte und
Pressefreiheit angeht eine Stunde
Flugzeit Singapur der Stadtstaat ist
heute eine finanzielle Brücke zur
Eroberung Asiens die großen Banken der
Welt versuchen hier ihr Glück
[Musik]
wir suchen zwei Personen gegen die die
örtliche Justiz ermittelt und die in der
BSI die wichtigsten Beziehungen zu Joe
low hatten den Schweizer Hans-peter
Brunner Direktor der BSI in Singapur und
Jaki den Büroleiter der für den
malaysischen vorarbeitete
was ja angeht haben wir ein Foto seines
Hauses nicht weit vom Stadtzentrum
entfernt
das ist es ja das ist das
guten Morgen wir sind auf der Suche nach
Herrn Jack ist nicht zu Hause
wissen Sie wann er zurückkommt ich weiß
es nicht er hat nichts gesagt vielleicht
nach dem Mittagessen
nach dem Mittagessen oder am Nachmittag
vielleicht am späten Nachmittag ja
hier gibt es nicht zu sehen wir werden
es später noch einmal versuchen wir sind
auch daran interessiert mit Jack für
eine weitere Sache dieser Geschichte zu
sprechen gegen jack wird heute in
Singapur ermittelt aber vor ein paar
Jahren hatte Alfredo Gysi lange Zeit die
Nummer eins bei der BSI in Lugano ihm
den berühmten und umstrittenen Brief
geschrieben indem er ihm für seine
hervorragenden Ergebnisse dankte die
einen Bonus von 19 Millionen wert sein
würden
unser zweites Ziel ist der Schweizer
Topmanager Hans-peter Brunner unter
seiner Führung hat die BSI in Singapur
in der Tat hervorragende Ergebnisse
erzielt eine aggressive Strategie viele
neue asiatische Kunden stark wachsende
Leistungen ein Anstieg der
Mitarbeiterzahl auf 250 ich meine ein
neues Eldorado für die Bank in Lugano
aber das Eldorado bröckelt auch nach dem
journalistischen Enthüllungen Agenten
der Mars Singapurs währungsbehörde
ermitteln wochenlang in der BSI
und am Ende sprechen Sie von einer
eklatanten und vorsätzlichen Missachtung
der Vorschriften durch die Bank
Entzug der Betriebserlaubnis und
Schließung des Instituts in Singapur
gegen Hans-peter Brunner wird derzeit
von der Mars und auch von der Schweizer
Aufsichtsbehörde ermittelt
aber wir waren auch wir hatten bereits
versucht ihn über seinen Anwalt zu
kontaktieren hallo ja guten Morgen herr
Rechtsanwalt ja guten Morgen mein Name
ist altes Sophia ich rufe für das Radio
und Fernseh der italienischen Schweiz an
okay nun ich habe mich gefragt ob sie
uns helfen könnten mit ihrem Klienten
Herrn Brunner Kontakt aufzunehmen
ich glaube nicht dass er gerade mit
Journalisten sprechen will gibt es dafür
einen bestimmten Grund
die Ermittlungen sind noch im Gange
daher können wir keinen Kommentar
abgeben deshalb ist es besser wenn er
nicht sagt
aber im Moment steht er unter Hausarrest
oder kann er sich in Singapur frei
bewegen
kommen nein denn Sie haben uns gesagt
dass sie ihm den Pass abgenommen haben
ich werde nicht darauf antworten
versuchen wir es mit einer E-Mail der
ehemalige Direktor der BSI in Singapur
antwortet freundlicherweise dass er
nicht bereit ist mit der Presse zu
sprechen auch weil er an das
Bankgeheimnis gebunden ist
[Musik]
iti sie haben bereits Hans-peter Brunner
kennengelernt aber auch in der
bsi-zentrale gibt es jemanden der meint
eine Bank in der Bank gegründet zu haben
Banken
Brunner kannte auch Joe Logo gut ebenso
wie die Mitarbeiter die im gefolgt waren
und mit Jolo direkt und illegal Geschäft
gemacht hatten kann es wirklich sein
dass ihm das alles entgangen war
das ist unser letzter Versuch Herrn Jagd
zu erreichen wir wissen dass Jagd der
auf frischer Tat ertappt wurde teilweise
mit der Justiz kooperiert eine gewisse
Verantwortung zu gegeben hat und
Bereiter zu wäre siebeneinhalb Millionen
Dollar zurückzuzahlen
das ist dein Auto los geht's
das ist die Dame von oben
guten Abend kennen Sie uns noch oh ja er
ist noch nicht zu Hause könnten wir mit
Herrn Jack sprechen noch nicht tut mir
leid wir haben die Frau oben gesehen
oh warten Sie einen Moment
woher kommen sie beide
bitte
wir bestanden darauf sie kam zurück sie
hatte mit jemandem gesprochen als sie
zurück kam sagte sie sie sei
ausgeschimpft worden das Dienstmädchen
muss ihm wohl gesagt haben dass wir
tagsüber vorbeigekommen sind schon
dreimal und jetzt haben sie auch noch
das Licht ausgemacht wir bleiben bis zum
Abend doch das Warten lohnt sich nicht
es ist auch möglich dass es ein
Sicherheitsproblem gibt und zwar ein so
großes dass der Staatsanwalt in den
letzten Tagen gesagt hat dass die Zeugen
und Jack gehört auch zu den Zeugen
dieses ersten Prozesses in Abwesenheit
vernommen werden könnten also ohne dass
sie in den Gerichtssaal kommen
weil es ein Sicherheitsproblem gibt
der Staatsanwalt hat das gesagt das muss
man ihm glauben
nicht einmal in der BSI in Singapur
wurden interne Kontrollen eingesetzt um
die illegalen Manöver von Joe und sein
Komplizen innerhalb der Bank aufzudecken
mit den antirisikomaßnahmen die die Bank
nach eigenen Angaben sogar verstärkt hat
und fordert sie auf mehr zu tun
wir kommen an den Punkt an dem die Finma
von Ihnen absolute Transparenz verlangt
das heißt der Kunde muss alle
Informationen angeben gab es absolute
Transparenz
ja bei einigen Vorgängen herrscht der
Transparenz aber an einem bestimmten
Punkt sagten die Kundenbetreuer im
Wesentlichen joolo dass sie für eine
bestimmte Einlage nicht alle
erforderlichen Informationen geben
könnten es handelte sich um Verträge
zwischen Regierungen und deshalb musste
das Staatsgeheimnis bewahrt werden
tatsächlich beschlossen wir die
Beziehung zu dem malaysischen vor
Manager zu beenden und das trotz der
Bedenken des Büros in Singapur und wer
hat den Singapur gezögert
im Verwaltungsrat der BSI in Singapur
waren Vertreter der Muttergesellschaft
Hans-peter Brunner war Mitglied der
Konzernleitung
eine sehr starke Verflechtung zwischen
der BSI Singapur und der BSI Agi
man kann sagen dass die grundlegenden
Informationen also alles was zur
Risikoeinschätzung nötig war immer mit
der Muttergesellschaft geteilt wurde
wenn nicht das richtig verstehe gab es
also Spannungen mit Brunner
ja aber das egal ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen dass Lugano erst in diesem Moment
von den etwa 100 konnten erfuhr die Yolo
eröffnet hatte
wie auch immer Lugano hatte immer die
Kontrolle und war für die Endkontrolle
verantwortlich
ich meine von wem hing es ab von Bert
Ammann
ja genau ich muss allerdings sagen dass
der verifizierungsprozess
installiert hat
der regulare das Protokoll wurde
eingehalten Protokoll ja und Ammann
beobachtete die Situation weiterhin und
der achtete alle Operationen von John
low als regulär regular aber er wusste
von der hohen Anzahl der von Joe low
eröffneten konnten natürlich wusste er
es aber entschuldigen Sie sie hatten
diese Informationen und er hatte sie
nicht erhalten soweit ich weiß hatte er
das nicht
ehemaliger Leiter der Abteilung Recht
und Compliance Schlüsselfunktionen für
interne Kontrollen anerkannter Fachmann
hatte schon mit der amerikanischen Akte
einen schlechten Start mit der Firma und
das würde der BSI nicht gerade
weiterhelfen
er traf sich persönlich mit Jolo und
ließ sich von dem Jungen Malaysia
überreden und behauptete stets das
aufgrund der Revisionsberichte bei One
MdB alles in Ordnung sei
gegen Arman läuft heute auch eine
Untersuchung der Firma
eine der wichtigsten Regeln bei der
Bekämpfung der Geldwäsche ist es zu
verstehen ob die Transaktionen
tatsächlich einen plausiblen
wirtschaftlichen Hintergrund haben die
Plausibilität
oder zu wissen wofür dieses Geld war
aber war das nicht ein Grund um Stopp zu
sagen das war ein Grund um zu sagen dass
man aufhören soll und das hat die Finma
auch so empfunden nicht die Bank die
Bank ging davon aus dass das Ende 2014
war sie ließ sich also Zeit vier Jahre
nachdem die konnten eröffnet wurden in
vier Jahren hatte eine Menge Geld
angehäuft eine Menge Geld
was ist das für ein System das eine Bank
einrichtet die alles verschwinden lässt
nun das wir sind nicht nur knapp bei
Kasse wir sind sogar ein bisschen drüber
wenn nun das waren die
Schlussfolgerungen in der Firma
welche teilen sie
nun die einschlagende Ankündigung vom 24
mai 2016 über das Ende der BSI scheint
die ehemaligen Führungskräfte die sich
zu wehren versuchen zu überraschen die
Bank bestreitet die Art und Weise und
zum Teil auch den Inhalt der
Intervention der Aufsichtsbehörde es
folgen dramatische Wochen eine schwere
Liquiditätskrise die Flucht vieler
Kunden mit einem relativen Verlust von
über 10 Milliarden und die
Beschlagnahmung von 95 Millionen wegen
vermuteter Gewinner aus superprovisionen
der letzte Akt einer der schändlichsten
Seiten der finanzpolitischen Korruption
Politiker finanzielle
Modus
er ist überrascht mich nicht dass der
kleinste gemeinsame Nenner des gesamten
one md-kante als sicherlich war
Geld das war Geld das
das aufgeteilt dazu geführt hat dass das
internationale Bankensystem als Ganzes
bei der Bekämpfung der Geldwäsche in
diesem speziellen Fall völlig versagt
hat
und noch einmal das heißt es ist das
Geld es ist die Menge an Geld die jedem
zur Verfügung steht die es ermöglicht
hat dass ein Diebstahl dieses Ausmaßes
überhaupt gelingen konnte
[Musik]
ich habe vier bis sechs Stunden gewartet
und konnte meinen Mann nur 20 Minuten
lang sehen
[Musik]
er konnte nicht sprechen als ich ihm das
Bild unseres Sohnes zeigte konnte er
nicht sprechen es war zu schwer für ihn
er hat seinen Sohn seit über einem Jahr
nicht mehr gesehen
[Musik]
nur sechs Personen haben Zugang zur
Zelle von Xavier ganz oben auf der Liste
die Männer von Petrus Saudi für Laura
ist es sehr schwierig ihren Mann zu
treffen alles so behauptet sie wurde
aufgezeichnet
[Musik]
da wir wussten dass Pedro Saudi alle
Aufzeichnungen unserer Gespräche im
Gefängnis
erhältlich
hatte ich die Idee mit Xavier über die
Gegensprechanlage über beliebige Themen
zu sprechen so dass Pedro Saudi etwas zu
hören bekommt währenddessen würde ich
Xavier aber über alles informieren was
ich draußen Tat zum Beispiel über die
Zusammenarbeit mit dem FBI indem ich in
einige Notizen lesen ließ die ich in
mein Notizbuch eingefügt hatte
lunika die einzige Möglichkeit ist vor
anderen zu verbergen bestand darin das
Notizbuch zu nehmen und es an die
Scheibe zu halten
[Musik]
von jetzt an werde ich dir alles
erzählen was ich tue und was wir tun
müssen
ich werde Thailand in Schutt und Asche
legen aber wir müssen es so aussehen
lassen als ob ich dort bleiben
der zunehmend kritische Zustand meines
Mannes und die jüngsten Drohungen die
ich erhalten hatte insbesondere gegen
meinen Sohn haben das fast zum
Überlaufen gebracht er hatte große Angst
noch mehr Angst um mich und unseren Sohn
aber ich schrieb ihm dass wir keine
andere Wahl mehr hätten und dass die
einzige Möglichkeit dem jetzt zu helfen
darin bestünde dass ich nach Genf
zurückkehre und alles öffentlich mache
die verstand dass ich mit der Presse
sprechen würde schickte er einen
gemeinsamen Freund der in ganz lebt um
mir mitzuteilen dass er hofft dass mein
Mann und ich keine Vergeltungsmaßnahmen
erleiden würden wenn ich aussagen würde
ST du
mich zu all dem getrieben hat dass der
Wunsch meinen Sohn in den Armen seines
Vaters zu sehen
denn mein Mann ist der beste Mann den
ich kenne der beste Vater den ich kenne
er ist kein Verbrecher im Gegensatz zu
dem was Petrus Saudi im glauben machen
wollte
dann nur damit mein Sohn seinen Vater
zurückbekommt und ich meinen Mann
zurückbekommen kann er Luder tut jeden
Morgen sage ich mir also aufstehen und
strahlen bis der Tag vorüber ist
dezember 2016 der neue König von
Thailand begnadigt 30.000 Gefangene
[Musik]
am 20 Dezember eskortieren thailändische
Einheiten den Kronzeugen zur Schweizer
Botschaft in Bangkok
am 21 Dezember schließt Xavier seine
Familie wieder in die Arme
[Musik]